what's going on there citizens of
the reject Nation we're gonna watch
Andor episode 11 today joining me is uh
the co-host of the weekly Year buddy I
was going for are you okay it's John
how are you John I'm I'm doing okay
I think they should leave a like
they should subscribe and hit the
notifications check out the patreon
page for full length reaction and
or where you sync up with your own cops
there's other shows too many other shows
by someone and the expressvpn we'll talk more
about them after the reaction because we love
expressvpn there's so much just installed over the
whole house I use it to break into other people
sometimes we're so safe now we can just privacy
I know exactly VM we do have set up in in this
entire home it's amazing so yeah we can't share
with you guys all right let's go do it foreign
make some seaweed moccasins they're
leaving I'm saying that they're living
I can't climb back up you hear me I hear
you my hands won't work I said I hear you
tell me to leave it they're living they're
leaving we'll save it for cassia okay she
would have wanted it that way heartbreaking
oh no what about the Droid no what oh my God
we're gonna take around a minute
if you want to say goodbye oh
I'll have them clear the room if you want to be
alone I really don't want to
be alone I want mama Marva oh
poor guy I can Google go with you the daughters
of pharynx require your assistance in matters of
grave importance we need to pull together B all of
us you're a member of this resistance too poor B
itch she die under what circumstances
oh I never wasn't even around for it oh poor B
it looks like it's just these two they
didn't walk here but if we go around
jump them and steal their clothes
yeah what uncomfortable conditions
even think that they never get back
in time if there's someone else either
we're getting out of you I know I feel
it God I feel every one of those stones
that's right right dude
oh dude no
she love what's up they're building a list of
grievances we want a funeral you're going to give
them a permit limit the time limit the numbers
we want to put them in a box stand back and watch
art draw him out to the public the dead are
bricked they mix your ashes with mortar and local
stone dust put your name on and fire it up you
become a block of ferric's brick wow and then what
they find you a wall backgrounds of the city
what a metaphor
a thousand each one for each of us that's
a great makeup water spoil here and foreign
hahaha you Millennials bitching
about the Empire what did he say s
like some judge dredge [__] damn where would
you be looking to run now eh yeah what oh
I'm so uneasy that was lucky wow what do you know
flies into the wall
street base I totally heard every
word they said definitely easy to
make it no problem turn off
those subtitles would you
he's about to get on edge
Great Frame my cousin I understand
she shops here senator mothma
tomorrow is too late where is he you're
off the rails you're lucky he's not here
not here I gave him eldani
what have you done lately Trump
meow I have always I have a constant blur
of plates spinning and knives on the floor
and needy panicked faces at the window
of which you are but one of many foreign
the mother died I'm leaving in the morning
Center says it's very busy though let him know
do that you two could have been Lovers In Another
Universe I was sitting here going kiss kiss
cut the tension if Santa dies it'll
happen time could go back to my place
I'm charging she's not hereby he's in the
stone now again we will wait to make sure
I'll leave you here alone is Droid is
breaking my heart nice day one night oh
best Droid in all of Star Wars I've gone
other way this episode to make
him like the most human aspect
s
oh God she's still there oh
yeah gotta break your mind oh
I'm going to ask you a question if I'm not sure
it's the truth I'll have to call back Dr ghost
Anto Krieger he's a big man
Big Man SpongeBob is this the man you
introduced to Cassie and Andor fix yes
oh she is so broken
foreign you guys are way too far with your
torturing man now she's more tortures you
gotta have the right amount of torture it's like
the fine go on the blocks at the right temperature
she loves it and her friends the only
thing she shows up on time for it really
she found the Elder don't tell me you're taking
proposals I'm in so much trouble though oh yeah
you are but you're not a thug I pulled everything
I could access up the hill into the main account
it was one empty Ledger at the end
of the line that was off balance
I don't make a Wells Fargo man I really need a
credit union Ma I went to Lutheran I told him
that I needed help from the outside that I need
the risk take home yes and you trust him yes I do
wants an introduction man I thought tea
could help me replace the credits and get
me started again but what he really did was
discover just how much more trouble I was in
oh how much is missing four hundred thousand
yikes it's like 200 American dollars inflation
Galactic inflation just leaving
now not really he warned me
who knows what he knows everything's
always right I found a solution
he's got an invitation you know Genevieve O'Reilly
does not get enough credit for how great she is in
this show absolutely not does not she's so good
just the amount here that's just like falling
apart and has to keep up a whole facade oh oh
she's so good I can hear her soul cracking yeah
just speak clearly indeed I think I've
been rugged for me lately but you know much
hey what's good in the office helping with the
Imperial transition my old partner still work in
the HQ night desk you phoned me this afternoon
and he told me that oh God the mother you were
talking about indoors she's passed away and to
her's mother did lots of back and forth with
Corazon about her are you saying that he's
there no no I'm in Moana where is zandor
we need to speak further
no the mystery of your former triumphs have
been vanquished I can sleep peacefully now
oh my God murder her and then switch off of
atnt I think he probably will kill his boss
he's got some Norman Bates in him
Master sneaker she never checked that
box I know nobody ever left that box
all those months I just left that box
there and whoever tends those rooms too
what's all this the sound Luther do not with
the speaker that took Cricket help Krieger I'm
in tell her to bring air power it's taking
a long time coming back to me sir you were
so eager for it is being knows Krieger's plan
he'll be waiting for it and how do we know this
I won't tell you that how do you know I won't
tell him I don't I don't know what you'll do
is far from ideal for either of us throwing
them into the dogs you're willing to burn him
you're the random Factor so you know
his doomed which means either your ISB
or you have someone inside that you are
protecting or I'm just a very good listener
worth losing Krieger
he's an ox what if it was me what would you do
Krieger doesn't know me I'm not vulnerable if
he's captured surely you've met him met him
I've been in a room with him but he doesn't
know that we send people we drop supplies we
have special radios he can't hurt me like I can
we'll let Krieger go down and play
the long game or do we warn him and
throw away his sources taken years to
cultivate you have people everywhere
don't you you're avoiding the question
all of your sources try to concentrate
someone with Krieger ISP maybe there's
someone here with me they're all fired
my man he tells me everything what is this
what kind of game is this
Krieger goes down the ISP will feel
Invincible we'll have a clear field to play
the alternative Craig pulls out we wave him off
they'll know they'll have to wonder trust
nothing just like you're doing it right now
all right right yeah kill creaker laughs and all
this 30 minutes I gotta make some ugly sacrifices
I killed vitamin for the greater good
call it what you will call it where you
will War the star war that's a good
scene I know it's Forest Whitaker's
best live action scene yet I'm most curious
about the other piece you should come home
is no longer available next we lose that and we'll
have to close shop I'm preparing for every outcome
sorry Lutheran you're going out going
through a tunnel Lutheran I can't hear you
oh no someone onto Lutheran
is our satellite Cruiser sorry
could you repeat back please
this is an imperial Patrol standby
for transponder scan ID foul
it's got a VPN yes this is all around
one two nine stand by horcroft run it
run it Darth helmet there's been partisan activity
in the area this is a piracy Zone oh thank you
for the warning oh I'll be careful you'll be
standing by it's what you'll be doing oh my God
what no Lutheran it's time
for space travel speeches
I'm gonna slap that wig back on
oh [__] disengage any propulsion
units and prepare to track the beacon
affirmative Patrol I have an engine
to jump to light speed tractor
beam has been engaged Warcraft
to power down your stabilizers
calibrary tractor Force calibrating
confirm request make a yo mama joke
sorry Patrol I'm a one-man show here I have to
manual these stabilizers ID confirm sir alderon
trade Alliance cancel the boarding no we can
use the practice oh my God yeah acknowledge
what are you doing tractor Force up
five does he think he can get away
who do you think he's gonna go final warning
whole craft power down immediately or risk
full consequences slam what are full
consequences countermeasures armed Wowie
oh my God sick from a whole Croft
practical Beacon is failing us I
can see that where's my Airway my shop is expiring
Tie fighters go Luther
you're the greatest pilot Booyah
broke their giant Wang beam
damn another one down
so cool
oh [__] we're great to tell you
that was great so proud of you
just shakes his head ruins of your
career right there is that one Freight
excuse me where's this oh dang
calcium I mean who
tell her I'm thinking about her
she'd be proud of me and I'll
get back as soon as I can can you
remember that your mother's dead
or a guy wrongfully thrown in jail well if we're
the only ones somebody's got to tell people what's
happening right there we need to split up
double our chances one of us has to make it
people have to know what's going on I
tell five friends you tell five friends
they each tell five friends
people have to know about this
oh dude they've been through the ringer together
it's the same kind of visual he would look at what
he left with Marva always comes back to her ah
really just how much Tony Gilroy hate Star Wars
just really leaks through every time it's so slow
all right okay let's talk about it because there's
a lot to talk about all right but before we talk
about the sandor stuff we got to think today's
video sponsor expressvpn uh really grateful to
them for not only sponsoring this channel once
again but for keeping all of our online business
safe and secure whether encrypted services and
IP address masking now I want to get this out
of the way yes many of us know what it's like
to use a Google incognito window thinking it's
safe and not traceable but you'd be wrong I
was scared to learn this I first started on
a Mr Sunday movies ad and then we looked it
up and yeah we should mention it too going
incognito on Google Chrome is good and all
until you realize that Google makes fortunes
by its users online activity and you can bet a
little incognito window isn't going to get in
the way of that and they've literally am I they
we mean Google have said as much claiming that
Incognito does not mean invisible whilst facing
a five billion dollar class action lawsuit here
in California for secretly collecting user data
so yeah guys we use a VPN because we've had some
scary situations happen to us there was one I've
never been public about but it was a nightmare to
deal with behind the scenes and fortunately we
were able to solve it but yeah implementing a
VPN has been a necessity and definitely highly
encouraged that everyone uses it now you have
other options for vpns you could use expressvpn
as the one the real rejects here have chosen to
have stuck with since day one and of course
you know one of the best parts about it you
know other than protecting your IP address your
personal info and your other sensitive online
activity it would be when you're trying to watch
Netflix in other countries and you see the shows
they get access to when you connect it to like oh
I connected my VPN in Japan what that's what they
get in Japan they get all the good stuff in Japan
you get all the best stuff friends in Japan Maybe
do you think so I don't know a lot of other people
who aren't America get friends and that's the
important thing that's the important change you
can pick anywhere in the world you want to be and
see what that Library looks like it's amazing
man every time you connect you'll get a random
IP address shared by other expressvpn customers
making you harder to identify and your data more
difficult to harvest it's super easy to use to the
point that one tap essentially protect your phone
laptop Smart TV all your dudes wow they really
want you to know like how easy it is to use it
yeah no expressvpn you got to fix your talking
so easy it's so much easier than that you just
select the country and you press a button there
you go then you hit go it's like when you hit
go on any machine you just go it's going and that
you're safe you're insane there you go now you're
in that country who needs to travel too many
words expressing you can turn on the VPN so if
you really truly want to go Incognito and protect
your privacy secure yourself with the number
one rated VPN visit expressvpn dot com slash
Rejects and get three extra months free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com rejects I wanted us to
spell it out for you yeah in case you can read
it because e is in Edward go to expressvpn.com
rejects to learn more uh if we can make fun of
them we've been using them already before they
paid us to talk about that yeah absolutely yeah
and you could bet the someone like Lutheran rail
knows the value of a good uh VPN the death of
so that was really sad man yes that was a very
somber episode I was very really sad everyone's
broken it's the Dark Night of the Soul
uh before we get to the finales would have
felt like to me next week's the finale yeah
yeah normally it's like an All Is Lost moment the
death of Marva yeah yeah yeah and just them being
entirely ostensibly alone the two of them for
now I mean even with Bix she's like so broken
they've done a number on her man holy [__]
yeah that was to the point where I was like is
she ever gonna like is her is her brain gonna
be scrambled just from here on out like is she
gonna have to like have someone take care of her
for the rest of her life due to this she's like
that horror movie character you visited an insane
asylum when you're looking for answers she hasn't
been able to talk clearly in years you won't get
anything out of her and she's like rips your ass
for you remember this code yeah yeah totally yeah
she's really morphed yeah and I mean it's funny
how like one you only see her for like one brief
sequence but it's among every like everything no
matter how brief it is always seems to come with
like a lasting punch and impact like no matter
how I like it it's it's interesting to see a show
where yeah it's like you have a lot of characters
and a character that could feel small just showing
up for one moment in an episode rarely ever gets
lost in the shuffle like they're really good at
making everyone's time important true whether
that be through yeah you know direct advancement
of the plot or just heartbreaking circumstance
well what's her name Clea yes the the Sona Sona
yeah yeah I'm waiting for CLIA to because I like
the presence of Cleo still waiting to latch
onto her more as a character though she's kind
of just there to whip some things into shape
she I think she rides the line well because
she is this sort of like executive assistant
who you can tell probably does a lot of badass
and difficult [__] behind the scenes but
mostly we just see her being very direct
and this episode in particular I was like okay
this is like the most we've sort of seen you in
action and I want to know more about you now
yeah yeah but to me I think like Vel and and
um Genevieve O'Reilly Mon mothma it's cool this
is the first time I felt like they were really
cousins yeah there was a real history with them
and I I think just the slowly broken soul of mon
mothma and the sacrifice that she really had to
make because you know it's sometimes in this act
of rebellion it's more like yeah you got political
figures with money who are secretly helping out
um and then here with mon mothma you you really
see that she wasn't just secretly helping out that
she was truly instrumental but she also had to
make some of the toughest choices of her personal
life and sacrificed so much and how much sacrifice
can she keep enduring until enough is enough like
how far can she go is she willing to give up her
family in like the most literal ways it's really
painful to see what she goes through and like
I I feel like even when like last episode you
know like like the highlights or the monologues
of like Andy Circus and stellen Skarsgard uh but
Mama did have a really powerful scene she's been
so consistent and then uh her scene here would
vowel when they're sitting on the couch together
you know braiding each other's hair painting his
nails having a pillow guys that's right do you
think Luther is cute I think Luther is cute no you
don't shouldn't I want Luther no you when they are
uh when they aren't talking with each other just
it just keeps getting worse and worse for her
and my notion of what her pivotal she would be
would be more that hopeful Spirit of the of the
Rebel excuse me the rebel rising and Dawning in
the middle of my Rebellion yeah I'm sorry but it
didn't turn into that at all uh it's it is crazy
just how relatable of a figure they have made
her and not just one of the nice people from
Coruscant yeah well because she suffers this makes
it clear how much she suffers in silence and like
she's already got Perrin who's a real winner
but you know even with her daughter it seems
like you know her family can't really know her
and she can't really be like emotionally close
to the people who do know her because of what they
have to work on so it seems like a very it really
Clues who into how harsh her position is and I
did love getting a moment between Vel and Clea
and and that whole you know like Val I like the
way they draw the fact that yeah you have their
familial tie but you also have both of their
ties to the rebellion and how different those
things are and how in one doing their job that can
step on the other's Toes or make the other's life
that much more difficult and it it's just like a
really fascinating Nuance that they don't really
even necessarily have to speak all the time but
yeah especially here it felt like they were even
in the emotional beats like actually yeah it's
funny you should say because yeah they do feel
like actually related I can see the sisterly kind
of Rapport between them and it's funny because
this is an episode that has so much Humanity
despite all the you know vicious circumstance
and I love that they chose to make be like the
most vulnerably emotional character even going so
far as to start like inside of his vision inside
of his eye just inside of like his perspective
when so much of the rest of the episode is shot
in ways that are very illustrative of isolation
you know and Val and clear are talking they're
both talking to negative space essentially uh and
all these like when marva's being carted out
it's all in these wides like there's so much
uh of the sterility and of the distance created
and I thought it was an interesting way to to
pull everything together yeah well I think
would be too he's a lot of times with droids
they one thing I've always liked about Star Wars
when it came to the artificial intelligence if
you will is that they 've never sometimes
they throw those bits of like shut the ripio
off just turn them off he's being annoying you
know yeah but more often than not they treat
droids like they actually have souls yeah
and that they're they are a living being
and I love that this show really leans
into that would be too and the same
people would create to us so you know like
the Tony Gilroy and so it would be too the
he is like a child lonely pet and uh I just feel
so much compassion for him of a destroyed learning
humanity and it makes me worried for him I wonder
what life be to ultimately has because he's not
a rogue one so what Journey does he go with
your mates with other droids have baby droids
there are two possible outcomes either he does
a daring sacrifice the last minute that allows
the rebels to get away one one more time or there
will be one of those like cassium again like go
on boy get out of here yeah go on I I don't need
you anymore go it's for your good you know just
uh yeah there are some things that I wish we would
get a little bit more fleshing out on like and or
melshi that moment would hit a little bit harder
for me other than the poignant themes of Rise
of rebellion and such like I don't even really
know who this guy is like I wish we had gotten
a little bit more time to see live with their
survival because I was enjoying the survival tone
of of just being like something that was like
borderline you know like those survival movies and
nature of like the edge or Revenant or some [__]
because you know like they're they're Barefoot and
Barren cold harsh wastelands and yeah it's it's
so it's so isolated and and such a vulnerable
situation to be in in the most physical way and
to me I'm like I wish we got to see was some
friendship bond with them so we could hear like
that way you feel a little bit more of a emotional
impact when they are like we have to tell everyone
or feel like what they've overcome together to get
there that part I feel was a little bit glossed
over like it was good what we got I did feel we
needed more of what of that though well yeah you
could fill out like a webisode or for my money you
could fill a whole episode for them to having to
stick it out and then finally get off world and
and then they you know go back to the beach and
find his case and all that stuff there's a lot of
emphasis on um Lolita leader leader the daughter
of Mama yeah there's a lot of emphasis on her and
I I guess kind of feel like whenever we see her
she's in a mood and the horse she's happy to be
in a good mood today if it is Chandra Leone
girl yeah I want to I want to I want more is
that over near the end I'm like there's emphasis
put here and you're kind of just like Moody kid
yeah yeah and then this episode with them being
like you know oh she she's really into you know
this uh you know this this Spirit you know the
the is it that they're studying the customs of
like the arranged marriage and stuff like that
is that what she's studying at the table there
with her friends dude whatever they're getting
into each other Customs or whatever yeah like
the the the old one they barely talk they just
barely Focus the spotlight on them boys that
feel nuanced that is the one way in which the it
does feel like the show is like oh yeah we're not
really that concerned with her and and I think
it could say something and add more to both mod
mothma's character but also latest character if we
did maybe drip into her perspective for a second
and see what she likes about these customers that
mon mothma isn't necessarily trying to thrust upon
her or whatever yeah because that's all part of
the conversation as well and especially because
it seems like Lita skews more towards Perrin is
probably like I doubt that my mother could full-on
just reliably say I could trust Leta if she were
to find out all the extent of what I've been
doing here so like it yeah I feel like you could
explore an interesting realm of indoctrination
and through that which yes pretty glossed over
here and then glossing over it it does feel
like you have moody teenagers are still over
there just not connecting with me you know and
I think this is one I'd probably get the most push
back on because whenever you say something you got
an issue with there's always someone who comes
in to tell you why actually and I'm open to it
you know I respect that you know tell me the the
the more positive perspective of this you know
um you hope zero wins okay yeah Cyril needs to
win they could be like here's my certificate of
approval mama I got a job in the actual Empire
no more private security for me you know but
I'm married she tells me what to do against my
cereals um she masculates me on the daily no I
love her teachers is morphed into oh you're that
one who appears in the monitors looking evil now
yeah yeah who needs it done and done now um
the Krieger I I wish we see him uh instead of
just hearing about him because I get the choice
because no one's really spending time with him
so it could just feel kind of random to just cut
to him like you're not even Lutheran knows him
uh like Luther knows him but Krieger doesn't know
that Lutheran is Lutheran yeah and so I I like I
I can see that the reasoning to not cut to him but
there's so much talk about him and there's so much
of a debate about what to do with the Krieger
situation should they just sacrifice him or
should they help him but by helping him that takes
care of the ISB officer that you know like there's
there's a dangerous him so I I love the debate
and I love the scene with saw Guerrera because you
know saw is like the ultimate case of a paranoid
junkie sure and and as I love saw a scene and
like I think that's all great and it's wonderful
debate like it does not eliminate at all um how
how wonderfully fleshed out these these uh scenes
of dialogue are and to be it's it's more like
I I guess it makes the debate what I like about
it is it makes the debate strictly about the
morality choice and the and the and the choice
of sacrifice even if you don't know who they are
which is much like War yeah you're like we gotta
go save this these people or these people are in
danger but they don't know them people I know or
my allies are about to be sacrificed to one degree
or another yeah so like ending on that note of I
call it War colored War I am the perfect person
that's me cuts my breath before we rise
uh I wonder if we would but I I but I'm
saying I would uh I would uh find it just more
I guess it makes sense to not show him because
it just puts you in the position they're in where
you're kind of choosing as an audience member
whereas if you're hanging out with Krieger you
might just be like well go save him he's Krieger
yeah I can't lose Krieger yeah we like creakers
yeah but removing that for the audience makes
us just think about the debate itself that's
why I see the strength in it um and and I
I just kind of want the emotional conflict
more and I would be more conflicted if I knew
Krieger just a little bit yeah that's a good
point and it it makes me wonder if we will see
that happen in some way next episode before he
gets his own Disney plus series that'll be the
new trend of how to do good Star Wars series is
get characters we know are going to die at the
end or or will die we've seen them die already
or something and then yeah we can tell a story and
leave nothing on the FL on the credits don't even
say who plays that they're out of this face and
it's not the guy from Borat it's not Ken Davidian
that would be awesome uh yeah I I wonder if we
will see it in some way I mean again judging by
how certain things were handled especially in
this episode but have been handled throughout I
wonder if whatever Glimpse we do get will still be
removed somehow sure yeah but I could also Imagine
doing some kind of thing where you have the Echoes
of this debate or something that isn't that battle
maybe intercutting with that operation going sour
or something like that right it just seems like
because they established that this thing's like
happening tomorrow and we can move immediately uh
you know and we've had this as a thread and like
they've talked enough it would also just help to
see Krieger so that you know it's it's among many
names and places thrown it's thrown out there that
are in conversation that aren't always on screen
so it would just be easier to keep track of anyway
but uh but also yeah I feel like they've done
enough building on this the same way they kind
of did without Donnie where it's like they they
laced that in and built it up and I feel like
it it would factor in but if it doesn't uh I I
think I I agree with you in the context of this
episode I'll be more maybe vexed about it if
we just never see it before The Season's done
but it's interesting yeah Cyril Rising he had
the funniest scene in the whole world there
was uh what we got we got two tubes credited
here I read that wrong the first time I don't
know I know who that is I like two tubes too
pick one and pick two yeah uh the Zone yeah
and I feel like there's uh oh yes and dude
luton's fight scene yeah that was a great
fight yeah that was a great fight he pulled
some [__] out of his ass he did he turned
on his VPN John Wick the Empire if you
wanted to dude he seems like you really
could it's like he just took out like five
Tie fighters see what just happened here
in a ship that's probably not designed to
take down five thai fighters because they
underestimated him that's true he took them
all out I mean it was like one of those spy
cars where you're like look at this piece of
[__] that you find it's equipped with all
like all kinds of like strips toothpaste launcher
whatever you need oil slick yeah this is so cool
um and he just whooped their asses it was like
so fast yeah and that dude just stand there
watch did he get out of oh what are those called
the the magnet puller thing as well tractor beam
um I did release the tractor beam uh
one million billion credits he he really
he gets added not only does he break out of the
tractor beam he also whoops a bunch of TIE fighter
asses I was like God damn how did this guy not
make it to Rogue one I know well he's gonna I
bet he's gonna die terribly I I feel like he has
to make it through the season too but he's he's
gonna they're gonna make an example of him I'm
sure cardiac arrest you think yes he's gonna die
completely unrelated he's just gonna slip and fall
down a big flight of stairs break his neck they're
gonna be like [__] a lot of stress that guy
has there's so many plans he didn't tell us about
what do we do yeah I just love how things ramp
up the colder he gets like the further they get
in this fight the colder he has to become and
and like the more his struggle to maintain his
morality is like a logical Endeavor yeah you know
the whole thing about it like I love partly that
scene between him and saw because it is like
I'm giving you the choice you clearly seem
to have like less dirt on your metaphorical hands
right right like also I'm leveraging you also I'm
trying to make you see what I see but also also I
think I need this like Clash of Vitality is just
to make sure that I'm still here as a moral being
because of how much I have to operate in the tools
and means that you know my enemy does so true
yeah um good good [__] but hey what are you
gonna do right what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do [__] happens sometimes your mom dies
but Andrew finding out that is really sad man and
if Bix doesn't probably gonna attend the funeral
no I'm sure she doesn't and I don't like part
of me wonders if she will ever recover and part
of me thinks she won't and part of me thinks
that's cold but also bold when she has makeup
on that means she's recovered that's right she's
a wonderful character recovering your lips are
all pale and your eyes are sunken in your whole
soul has been destroyed but you clean up nice
no I respect them for putting her out of makeup
sure because I'm it bothers me in shows when
they're like too afraid to put their actor I mean
she's obviously wearing makeup she did lip swag
for torture film makeup to enhance the physical
distress turmoil she's in the no makeup makeup but
they did it yeah make her like oh let's pretty
her up despite this terrible situation she said
um yeah because obviously she is
oh my God like horrendous looking woman what
you really got to be worried about is the guy
who sees this episode and goes that's your
best look baby be wary of that guy yeah no
Audrey Arjona is a gorgeous woman she
is um and a talent to behold as well
yeah guys uh what did you think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
and uh yeah I'm just [__] I'm yawning all
right let's uh let's give it to do a patreon
you I've been here for 55 months that's over four
years you've served in the rain check for belly
thank you Mikhail for being part of our patreon
for so long man damn I just looked at your address
for the first time I will never know how to
pronounce that or write it on an envelope
wow in a way that gets to you crap how does that
make any sense so for the amount of time you've
been with us um you have never swayed once
you've always been very encouraging and kind
and I think all we know is that you're from Sweden
and you like James Bond and I think after a few
years we want to know a little bit more consistent
character in this universe they knew exactly who
you were when they wrote you words quirks just
lean into that all the time how do you relate
to a James Bond character haha yeah so it's kind
of funny that you know to see you I don't think
you've changed your profile pic once this whole
time no I love it never change it uh but Mikhail
you're a beautiful guy you're you're
a gem you know that your Swedish gem
and uh you're hotter than all the Swedish girls
out there like I'm gonna type in Swedish girls
don't do that on Google no why what happens uh you
know I'm sure you've got a virus I'm sure it'll
be appropriately appropriate for Swedish girls
myths about Swedish women confirmed and busted
Mikhail oh my God these women these are women oh
oh dude they're like Audrey arahono without makeup
oh god get a feeling get it off my screen how to
impress Swedish women the comprehensive guy just
the first article what it's not like impressing
any other kind of woman let me tell you hail you
have been uh tell them you know Michaela that's
not your sweet you've been living it up Mikhail so
congratulations on all the success I'm very proud
of you all right we'll talk soon buddy foreign